should we get more on that uh with
annalise dodds who's standing by for his
shadow secretary of state for women and
equalities and chair of the labour party
hello to you andres dos thanks for
joining us on the programme um
it was interesting to chat to um the
greater manchester mayor i'm sure you've
worked with him previously when he's
been in the palace of westminster he
feels that the labour party is not
necessarily going far enough on things
like nationalizing the energy uh
companies it seems that we've seen i
don't know have we have we seen a u-turn
on that
no we haven't since while i agree with
andy on very many things i think
actually the really clear contrast right
now is between
labour's fully costed plans to stop
people having to pay those enormous
projected increases this ottoman winter
with their energy bills
and the complete lack of action from the
conservatives and that's not to do with
there being a leadership contest on with
the conservatives it's because of the
fact that neither of the candidates have
been clear about what they would do
to get those energy bills down labour
has been clear we have that policy
to keep the current cap to not let it go
up any further we spelled out exactly
how we'd pay for that we'd pay for that
with a windfall tax now of course that
was described as an incredibly too
radical measure for a very long time
particularly by the conservatives but by
others as well eventually we dragged the
conservatives kicking and screaming to
implement one version of it but with
huge loopholes we'd bung up those
loopholes we'd start it earlier we'd use
that another means to pay to keep that
cap where it is at the moment and that's
the big contrast actually in british
politics at the moment of course andy's
right to say people need the basics and
labour's showing how we would deliver
that i just wish that the conservative
leadership candidates would listen
you say it's not a u-turn but i was just
looking at the manifesto for the last
election
and part of that was to say that
the energy and mail and rail would be uh
nationalized
okay of course
every party changes their manifestos
over time i've just been talking about
the immediate measures that labour would
be taking right now to deal with those
energy costs i think that's what many
people are worried about having heard
the news recently about the hike in the
cap that's coming up very very soon but
you know as labour has been very clear
in seeing we are pragmatic we're
pragmatic about how for example our
energy system is run in our country
we're pragmatic about the role of public
ownership within energy it needs to
operate within those fiscal rules that
were set out by rachel reeves at our
last party conference needs to work for
our country and that's the key thing
that's of importance for us as labour we
want to get a grip on those long-term
problems that have affected our country
i would say when it comes to energy as
well in particular we want to get a grip
on the extremely poor quality of energy
insulation that we have in our country
we've got some of the worst insulated
homes in all of europe right now that's
why we said that we would be insulating
britain as well so again that big
contrast between labour that's pragmatic
that's clear about what we would change
and the conservatives when there's
simply no plan at all
well you say that there's a thought that
potentially vat could be cut
and i know that was something that
gordon brown actually implemented didn't
he when he was prime minister is cutting
v80 a viable option to save the public
from higher bills
well we think it's important to focus
specifically on energy because not only
is energy critical for bills as you said
okay it's also critical of course when
it comes to inflation it contributes a
lot to that spiraling inflation that
we're seeing at the moment that's why
labour's plan is firmly focused on
energy bills
on stopping those bills from increasing
again with that projected rise in the
cap we set out exactly how we would
deliver that now we've seen a whole
range of different policy kites being
flown by the different conservative
candidates neither of them have
explained how they will pay for what
they're setting out neither of them have
actually stuck over time to what they
said they would put into practice a big
difference there compared to labour
because we've been saying since january
that there needed to be a proper
watertight windfall tax on the oil and
gas companies they've been making record
profits we should be using that money to
get people's bills down that's what
labour would be doing right now
um there's vat on energy bills isn't
there
there is an image built down in flat key
we call for that v80 to be removed we
called for that to be removed a very
long time ago it seems as i said that
some of the candidates now may be
supporting that some of the conservative
continuity candidates trust uh and rishi
sunak do seem to be saying now that they
might support that of course labour
again at the time set out how we would
be paying for that we're not seeing that
from the conservative candidates that is
a problem but we're particularly not
seeing k that action targeted on energy
bills under labour we would not see that
cap increasing uh in the coming months
because we would be using that windfall
tax to get those bills down neither of
the conservative candidates have
promised to do that but they should be
saying they would do it now because that
would take so much worry off so many
people's shoulders
okay um it's always great to see ms
dodds thanks so much for taking the time
pleasure